Doutor, fale um pouco sobre falta de
cobre. Meu exame de sangue deu baixo.
Bem, esses dias eu estava conversando
com um paciente aqui que chegou no
consultório arrastando os pés
literalmente. Ela me disse: "Doutor, eu
tô cansada que só vendo e olha que eu já
tomei de tudo, ferro, vitamina B12,
vitamina D, fiz de tudo e foi aí que
acendeu aquela luzinha na minha cabeça.
Será que quem investigou antes não
estava esquecendo de alguma coisa?"
Pois é, meus amigos, hoje vamos bater um
papo sobre o mineral que muita gente nem
sabe que existe o nosso corpo, é o
cobre. E olha só que interessante, o
cobre não é só aquele metal que a gente
vê em fio elétrico, não. Dentro do nosso
organismo, ele é tipo um maestro de
orquestra, regendo mais de 12 enzimas
diferentes. Imagina só essas enzimas que
a gente chama de cuproenzimas
são responsáveis por um monte de coisa
bacana, desde produzir energia nas
nossas células. até formar a melanina
que dá cor pro nosso cabelo e pele. É ou
não é uma belezura da natureza? E sabe o
que mais? O cobre é fundamental pra
gente absorver o ferro direito. É como
se fosse aquele amigo que te apresenta
pra galera numa festa. Sem ele, o ferro
fica meio perdido e não consegue entrar
na corrente sanguínea como deveria. Por
isso que muitas vezes a pessoa toma
ferro e não melhora nada na anemia. Tá
faltando apresentador. Então, lembre-se,
cobre pode ser o que faz a diferença na
anemia. Agora, deixa te contar uma coisa
que tá acontecendo muito hoje em dia.
Com o aumento das cirurgias bariátricas,
sabe aquelas cirurgias de redução de
estômago paraa obesidade mórbida, a
deficiência de cobre virou um problema
mais comum ainda. Estudos recentes
mostram que até 20% das pessoas que
fazem essa cirurgia podem desenvolver a
hipocupremia, ou seja, falta de cobre. É
muita gente, não é? E não é só isso,
não. Tem outras causas que a gente
precisa ficar de olho. Uma coisa que
pouca gente sabe é que o zinco em
excesso pode ser o vilão da história.
Sabe quando a pessoa toma aqueles
suplementos de zinco por conta própria,
por causa da imunidade, por exemplo, ou
para aumentar a testosterona, achando
que tá fazendo de bom? Pois é, o zinco e
o cobre competem pela absorção no
estômago. E geralmente o zinco ganha a
briga. É tipo dois irmãos brigando pelo
controle remoto e o menor sempre sai
perdendo. Os sintomas da falta de cobre
são bem chatinhos. A pessoa fica com uma
fadiga que não passa nem com reza brava,
uma anemia que não melhora mesmo tomando
ferro. Às vezes aparece uns
formigamentos nas mãos e pés que
incomodam bastante. Tem gente que até
desenvolve problemas para andar direito,
como aquela minha paciente que eu
mencionei no início. E olha que curioso,
alguns pacientes relatam que o cabelo
começa a ficar grisalho mais cedo. Faz
sentido, né? Seu cobre ajuda a produzir
melanina, que é o corante natural. Na
medicina funcional, a gente sempre
procura entender o porquê das coisas.
Não adianta só repor o cobre e tchau.
Tem que investigar, será que é má
absorção intestinal, doença celíaca,
doença de crom? Ou será que a pessoa tá
tomando algum medicamento que atrapalha?
Por exemplo, antiinflamatórios,
antibióticos e analgésicos podem
interferir na absorção do cobre. OK? E
aqui vai uma dica de ouro. Ou melhor,
dica de cobre. Os alimentos campeões
desse mineral são as ostras. Eu acho uma
delícia. Fígado bovino, que eu sei que
nem todo mundo curte. Castanhas, que eu
adoro também, especialmente a castanha
do Pará, que é a nossa queridinha
brasileira, semente girassol, semente de
abóbora e cogumelos. Aí tem uma novidade
interessante. Estudos mostram que o
cacau puro também é rico em cobre.
Imagina só, tomar um chocolate quente
pode ser terapêutico.
Quando a deficiência é mais severa, aí
não tem jeito, precisa suplementar
mesmo. Geralmente usamos o gluconato de
cobre ou cobre picolinato ou cobre
glicina, cerca de 2 mg por dia, mas isso
varia de pessoa para pessoa. Pode variar
de 1 mg até 5 mg. E tem que acompanhar
direitinho com exames, OK? Não é para
sair tomando por conta própria, porque o
excesso de cobre faz mal, intoxica. É
aquela história do nem 8 nem 80. Uma
coisa importante que descobrimos é que
alguns nutrientes ajudam o cobre a
funcionar melhor no nosso corpo. A
vitamina B6, a vitamina C e até mesmo o
cobre trabalham juntos como uma equipe.
É como montar um time de futebol. Não
adianta ter só o atacante bom, precisa
do time todo funcionando.
O monitoramento é fundamental, galera. A
gente não olha só o cobre no sangue, tem
que olhar os minerais de modo geral. Tem
que chegar também uma proteína
carreadora que é a ceruloplasmina. É a
proteína que carrega o cobre, a
ferritina também, que é a proteína que
carrega o ferro. E às vezes até fazemos
testes mais específicos. E sabe o que é
legal? Com o tratamento certinho, a
maioria dos sintomas melhora em dois ou
três meses. Mas atenção, os problemas
neurológicos podem demorar mais para
melhorar e, em alguns casos, podem não
reverter completamente. Por isso é tão
importante diagnosticar cedo. Então,
pessoal, a mensagem que fica é: se você
tem aquela fadiga que não passa, anemia
que não melhora com ferro ou sintomas
neurológicos estranhos, vale a pena
investigar os seus níveis de cobre.
Nosso corpo é uma máquina incrível e
complexa e às vezes são os detalhes
pequenos como mineral que a gente nem
lembra que existe, que fazem toda a
diferença. Cuidar da saúde é isso,
prestar atenção nos sinais que o nosso
corpo dá, investigar todas as
possibilidades. Afinal, como eu sempre
digo pros meus pacientes, não existe
saúde de verdade sem equilíbrio.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar. também no canal do
Doutor Além do Tr se envolva.